Let's calculate
the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame of
two objects that are colliding.
I'm going to use prime for the
center of mass frame velocity.
So we have V1 prime.
And we have V2 prime.
And recall two things that
when we calculated V1 prime
in the center of
mass frame, we found
that this was equal
to the reduced mass
divided by m1 times
the relative velocities
of the two objects, V1
prime minus V2 prime.
Now in the center of
mass frame, this quantity
is a reference
frame independent.
And so we can just
write that as V1, 2.
It's the relative velocity is
reference frame independent.
So we also knew
that V2 prime was
equal to minus mu over m2 V1, 2.
So now let's calculate
the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame.
So K cm is 1/2 m1
V1 prime squared
plus 1/2 m2 V2 prime squared.
Now let's use our results in
terms of relative velocity.
So we have 1/2 m1 mu
over and m1 times V1,
2 squared-- because
we're squaring
that-- plus 1/2 m2 mu-- the
minus sign doesn't matter
anymore because
we're squaring it--
V2 squared-- I could put that
in there, it wouldn't matter.
And now what we
have is we have 1/2.
One of the m1s cancels so we
have a mu squared over m1 V1, 2
squared plus 1/2 another
mu square over m2 times
V1, 2 squared.
So I pull out the common terms,
mu square, V1, 2 squared.
I have 1 over m1 plus 1 over m2.
But recall that the reduced
mass was precisely 1 over m1
plus 1 over m2.
And so I get 1/2 mu
times V1, 2 squared
is the kinetic energy in
the center of mass frame.
So what that means
is a way of thinking
if this were just a
simple reduced mass
problem with a relative
speed of V1, 2 squared,
I can write down
the kinetic energy.
But that's the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame.
And therefore, the change in
kinetic energy in a collision
is just 1/2 V1, 2 V
final squared minus--
and it's the same
mu, so we'll just
put a parentheses-- minus
V1, 2 initial squared.
And if the collision
is elastic-- remember,
our elastic collision
show that V1, 2 initial
was minus V1, 2 final.
So an elastic collision
satisfies that condition.
And you can see directly that
delta Kcm is 0 in that case.
And a completely
inelastic collision
has the two objects moving
together at the end.
So V1, 2 final is 0.
So completely inelastic is
the condition that V1, 2 final
is 0 because the
objects stick together.
And then have a
very simple result
for the change in kinetic
energy for completely
inelastic collision.
It's only negative 1/2 mu V1,
2 initial quantity squared.